concordo porta chiamato basso ma rosso
stato eliminato
ci stupiamo venuti sono i castori ha
grandissima atleta oggi il nuovo
gameplay dio mondo se avete cosa degli
ato di giocare in un modo e cioè giocare
tutti in una stanza jackman si può
essere la quale la stanza giocheremo
tutti in caffetteria e chi esce dalla
stanza avrà perso quindi l'impostore
dovrà riuscire a chiudere il crew nate
senza farsi vedere era molto più
difficili dentro la stanza invece creò
mez non dovranno fare le trasforma
dovranno semplicemente coprire chi è
l'impostore quindi dovremo fare tutti
gli investigatori è però un'altra
aggiunta e cioè le luci sono diminuite
quindi siamo tutti al buio così sarà
ancora più difficile che per l'impostore
uccidere tremezzo sempre in credito e
trovare un aspetto di impostare sarà
troppo divertente lascia come vi piace a
questo video e se volete che facciamo
un'altra partita con voi da questo video
range 10 mila mi piace fare un prossimo
gameplay di hammond ora mettetevi comodi
treni ma occorre iniziamo subito e
sicura
abbiamo ridere le regole nella chat il
vitale stiamo giocando separato non
guardare iniziamo subito e video frutti
sì ma io guardo come potete vedere c'è
pochissima luce quindi riuscito a
eliminare qualcuno oppure siamo tutti
caffetteria avanti se non si può dire
dove ma in cantoria nella pagina tra
sinistra ma verdi score lo stesso che ha
detto nella parte in alto a sinistra
bene sappiamo
[Musica]
cerchi la marrone ha accusato barry
diamo allora io devo dire che con questa
modalità
ho molta paura perchè ti ritrovi molto
vicino il crew mail o impostore non lo
so
sospetti un po di tutti allora io seguo
il marrone perché secondo me e marrone è
un impostore
anzi siamo dimenticati di dire che
esistono giunto un altro che un pastore
avesse molte difficoltà in questa
modalità invece di impostare di pastore
rilascio proprio bene perché marrone
prima aveva incollato verde invece verde
non era impostore quindi secondo me e
morrone
nodis tutti quanti marrone non velato
tutti maturi
speriamo di non essermi sbagliato se non
sarai una sospetta si ritirano gli
immensi meeting che ha chiamato le
emergenze meeting celeste vorrei
incolpare me mito concordo
ford ha chiamato
2 già no non sono io giuro roll it era
con me bianco mi sta difendendo baguette
bianco moto celeste anch'io punti season
vara per il tempo guardiamo non era
imposto è vero per un solo libro è
assurdo come l'impostore stia riuscendo
bene confiscato più facile per noi crew
mail invece no è più difficile
secondo me se si sospetta comunque la
guarda già hai fatto uscire fuori tre
persone
no non voglio che vincano gli inventori
stesse non c'è nessuno qua dove siamo
rimasti pochi sono rosso sono gli yacht
un secondo me vitale sospetto è sempre
stato a difendere tutti
ci credo oggi ero io l'impostore mi ha
sbattuto fuori però rialzi non merita né
sapevo che eravamo io giallo di un fusto
ricche e vitale è stato buttato cuore
perché allora ho pensato di persone
stanno provando a entrare sempre così i
codici li condivido su instagram quindi
se non mi seguite su instagram b da
quando andate a seguirmi e questa volta
giochiamo ma nel reattore vediamo che
vinceranno anche questa volta gli
impostori ormai creates mi chiamo più
mail
secondo me è più facile da impostare
fisico nel reattore antica essendo più
piccolino o no ovviamente l'impostore a
è giusto votare il re non si possono
neanche chiamare gli emergency meeting
perché siamo né solo nel reattore gruppo
in un post a stesso nesta importanza
perché animo non è che per i tool
eravamo in gruppo io non ho uno ti ha
votato prossimi a moroto tatticamente
si possono però su via togni auto di
arredo tutti bravissimi siete tumori
dirigenti quando visitiamo le regole
quelle seguite sempre poi magari si
scopre che ci ha colpito basi nella
mappa che si sta chiedendo letto le
regole nel posto su instagram un ottimo
che succede come sono tutti
non mi sento questa volta no
una volta per gli impostori e per gli
importi sono due è un po difficile
avverrebbe un sacco di altre cose
scoperti
no no no no non bisogna mai stare troppo
appiccicati perché poi dopo per
l'impostore è più facile perché vai
spara nel mucchio e quindi di verde
prendere questo blu non bisogna pure
così perché così troppo furbo perché
tutti quanti vanno lì e quindi nel
mucchio il primo che ha proiettato credo
che siamo tutti nella sua sostanza e
nonostante non riusciamo a vedere
impostore ma come cani state dicono nero
mi è sembrato che sia stato nero
nero come mai riporti sempre tutto nero
nero ok tv né rosa perché sempre in nero
che sei riprese se non siete stati
bravissimi perché l'avete visto che c'è
qualcuno che sta scappando di lavoro
ecco la blu anche blu e sospetto secondo
me non dando a chiamare un emergency
meeting forza no non possono perché
dobbiamo stare tutti qua
osservate bene tutti giallo è molto
sospetto già lavorino una finta come mai
perché siamo tutti così appiccicati e
non vediamo mai motore ma poiché ci sono
la valigia pay to rosso continua ad
accusarsi magari non ero stato carino no
siamo noi di merda merda fantasy
scopriva che vediamo fia vediamo chiesto
e vero anche perché noi abbiamo tutta la
visuale adesso va bene ora controlliamo
bene bene visto che abbiamo tutte le
luci vediamo e come uccide di narzole
quindi sono arancione nessuno aveva
sospettato di arancio almeno rientra
limitata a lei è sacrificato votato
compra ancora il gioco in cui bisogna
solo dire la verità ve la ricordate non
avete visto il video in cui bisogna solo
dire la verità in strumenti n'è andato e
poi arancione fuori ordinanza
e allora come sempre vitale non riesce
entrare perché troppo perché farlo
entrare comunque questa volta la stanza
traccia pronti vediamo se saremo
impostori speriamo il pastore ok
secondo me in questa stanza strappini
fine trovare imposto sembra grande però
è grande beh in confronto al reattore se
molto più spazio per i due impostori per
farci fuori sospetto nero erano troppo
non ci credo l'impostore ha sabotato lo
stige no pur sapendo che noi non
possiamo uscire dalla stanza
quindi questo sarà uno strappo alla
regola dobbiamo per forza uscire e
sistemare in ossigeno perché questo non
poteva farlo li portò no non ci credo
l'impostore ha nuovamente sabotato non
so cosa quindi qualcuno dovuto sia al
corpo di verde che c'era vicino sì anche
noi abbiamo visto giallo spero che sia
giallo ci sono dei sospetti sul giallo
[Applauso]
lo stagno abbiano sma nota brutto
abbiamo visto ok allora ho scritto nella
chat di non sabotare se impostori
altrimenti bisogna salire non vale il
gioco questa volta la santa sarà
electric quindi sarà ancora più piccola
mettete sopra che strano stiamo sempre
il posto noi siamo sempre state partita
perché tranne vitale che i vitali capita
impostore o no dovevo dare dall'altra
parte adesso piazza
solo che sono io il posto ma non si
mettono nel 19 st le luci però sono
stati bravi di impostori perché tutti
hanno fatto in modo che ti butto etico
passato ma le cifre del blu
ok schifiamo questo perché è impossibile
prezzo saranno tutti quando tutti sotto
unito la strana script mani si smetta
libero questo perché evitare torniamo
subito in electric e così tutti qua
allora osserviamo bene osserviamo bene
bianco aiuto con le luci di gusto niente
chi è ancora più difficile un corpo
lione ma perché ce l'aveva voluta dal
travolta unite rimane sempre state dio è
colpo di evitare che scrive queste cose
2 9 da due e 2 dalle luci agli impostori
devono approfittarne sembra tutto ok
piace contro detto che ero sospetto
bianco o no
bergamirco hanno il dono hai visto
perché l'avevo incolpato di io voglio
prima adesso forse bianco
decisamente no perché noi amati
eliminati che sta ormai freddo io no
continua a dire bianco ha fatto anche
state lo scriviamo non lo puoi vedere
isolanti 4 magari anche perdere
l'impostore sono due no
eccolo arancione diamo dai un'altra
partita bonus anche se ho detto che era
l'ultima sono troppo felice di giocare
il masters anita spesso prova mentre mi
spiace non mi fa strano per chi non
riesce a giocare con noi ma purtroppo il
limite è 10 è bancata a pranzo oggi che
siamo 9 di dieci mai a nessuno ricercare
anche meno vitale quindi non so perché
siamo impedì 10 comunque allora ho
scritto scegliete voi la santa ora che
vi potete sei mesi un pakistano
per le più elettrica perché lì entrata
quindi due modi per elettrica
[Musica]
ok pronti a mohe 3 2 1 che abbiamo fatto
bene a fare questa alle luci e no perché
se come siamo impostori viviamo di più
degli altri
se si può fare venir ip l'impostore vuoi
vedere di prudente pc che si è visto
rosso sasso niente non potremo che
devono sospettare di noi dobbiamo
cercare di vincere dai post basso sas ma
rosso è stato eliminato ha ucciso in
giallo se ho visto bene quindi anche il
giallo non c'è più però qui verde che
devo dire
perdenti ma contiamo verde scuro o dopo
tanto verde chiaro io non ho visto
niente reti scuro
che bravo lui che i fattori vediamo
tempo stiamo bene perché dobbiamo
provare a vincere da imposto la prossima
volta però possiamo provare a ridurre le
luci anche per gli impostori così sarà
molto difficile anche parte l'impostore
devo dire che questo pur divertente
poter vedere tutto in più potremmo anche
entrare dentro il vento per nasconderci
sperando che non si vedono ma forse un
po rischio oltre che ci sia scappato
qualcuno è scappato
sì ho visto qualcuno che è scappato ho
visto chi dic
sembra via dino viola crisi più mezzo
togliamo perché abbiamo probabilità di
zinola fuori
rimaniamo in pochi forse vinciamo forse
vinciamo tempo no aspetta nessuno è
stato espulso perché c'erano anche due
skip che diamo le luci in elettrica vico
ti fanno tutti lì visto che si stanno
sparpagliando ora chiuso hanno chiuso la
porta al suo stato io si asciuga la
borsa luciano tutti entrare o no visto
qualcuno che hanno visto celeste che
viola sasso hanno tutti incolpando i
crimini perché l'informale carcere
questa volta pensavo meglio di tutti
circa mamma ma diciamo guarda se vorremo
stituto due impostori
ok non lo sa con un altro non sta bene
persone all'ultima partita e pato troppo
divertente giocare in questa modalità
passate un bel mi piace mi raccomando a
10 mila mi piace nuove partite con voi
ora vediamo quanti casalinga
semplificare per vedere i nostri altri
video cliccate su quella che preferite